so in this video I'm going to talk about
nuts alright
why because one of the most common
problems that I have run in to people
that start to eat healthy as they start
having reactions to nuts they don't know
that nut is they're reacting to that nut
and so or peanut butter so here's here's
the problem if you consume too much nut
or seeds or peanut butter it is severely
aggravating to the gallbladder and the
ducts that connect to that gallbladder
all right so just be aware of that and
many time you're looking for a snack
that is um quick it's satisfying and
you'll have these nuts if you do too
much it's gonna irritate this
gallbladder but it's it's you may feel a
little bloating okay you're gonna feel a
little bloating in your stomach but
there's a little nerve that goes right
to that gallbladder and it goes right up
to the liver and it goes right up to the
shoulder and right up to the neck and up
to the head in other words this little
nerve will be pinched down here like
you're stepping on a dog's tail but he's
going to bark over here and you're going
to have neck pain on the right side or
the shoulder anywhere on the shoulder it
could even go all the down to your right
leg so anything on the right side the
body and even on the right shoulder
blade on the right side behind your
shoulder
you'll feel a little thing on the back
where it's tight all the way through
here and you will swear it's probably a
neck pain or a shoulder problem when in
fact it's those nuts so realize that
could be one of the sources of that
headaches are usually that as well and
definitely neck tightness or your neck
becomes very rubbery in and naughty and
it can also create a lot of tension in
the upper shoulders okay up here I would
say that 90% of the people that I see
that come in with neck pain headaches
upper back pain and shoulder pain in the
right side or the upper back pain
mid-back pain it has to do with this one
problem the gall bladder right here or
they're consuming nuts or it could be
from other so
but nuts are a common thing so you just
asked ask yourself when did the pain
start what did I eat just before it and
it probably will be these nuts right
here so there's a couple things that you
can do to determine if that's the thing
or not I just had a lady recently come
in and she just can't turn her head and
she was about to get surgery for her
neck and I says hold on I said let me
just try something
so I basically pressed up underneath her
right ribcage right over the gallbladder
okay so your ribcage comes here you
press right on the right side about an
inch off the center to the right and
just press in there and hold that for
about a minute and if your neck loosens
up then we know it's this problem right
here and if you say well I already have
my gallbladder out so problem solved
realize that if you have that globular
out you definitely have a problem there
because now you just have a tiny little
duct that's always gonna be plugged up
especially if you overload too many nuts
or oils and/or fats or olive oil or flax
oil or any of these oils that people are
taking or fish oils and you start
burping it up so a symptom of gall
bladder problems would be belching right
shoulder pain headaches burping acid
reflux a lot of bloating and congestion
right there and the neck stiffness right
here so two things you have to actually
change your eating and you need to maybe
do some some acupressure over the
gallbladder and that will give this a
lot of relief
there's also another acupressure point
that you can use on the left calf down
by the ankle there's going to be a lot
of tenderness right there and you work
that out and that will free up this
right shoulder as well and neck if
that's the cause of it another thing if
you want to germinate your nuts that
sound kind of strange if you want to
soak your seeds and nuts overnight
that's called germination and here's
what you can do you can get out like a
container fill it with water put your
nuts in there and seeds and then then
let it soak for overnight okay and then
rinse it out real good and then dry it
in the oven
like at 150 degrees or a dehydrator when
you consume those nuts then you will
have less of a irritation in your gall
butter because when you germinate these
seeds and nuts you actually release
certain properties in there they're
called enzyme inhibitors which basically
help that just than not these enzyme
inhibitors basically block the enzyme in
a natural form raw nuts that prevent the
digestion and that's why a squirrel
always buries his nuts in somewhere in
the soil before he eats them so we want
to soak them and germinate them if
you're consuming roasted nuts
it's already the enzyme inhibitors
aren't there so I know it's kind of a
hassle to do that so it's okay to have
some raw nuts but just make sure they're
there low quantity and if you start
getting neck pain or shoulder pain then
you're gonna have to lower that as well
and you can take two digestive enzymes
and things like that but just realize
there's a huge connection between the
relationship between seeds and nuts in
peanut butter
and pain in your neck and the shoulder
one last point about that is that when
you buy peanut butter read the label and
make sure it does not have any added
sugar or just peanuts salt
preferably sea salt in oil that's it
okay so I hope that helped and go ahead
and start germinating your seeds in your
nuts